[Music]
birds of prey is being described as a
girl gang movie set in the DC Cinematic
Universe following Margot Robbie's
Harley Quinn as she takes Gotham City on
her own terms now that we've seen the
film's first trailer we know more than
ever about why these birds are flocking
together as a character Harley Quinn has
largely been defined by her toxic
relationship with the Joker that was
certainly the case in 2016 Suicide Squad
but she's leaving her footing behind in
Kathy yen's new movie the fantabulous
emancipation part of the title refers to
the fact that Harley Quinn has broken up
with the Joker and she confirms as much
in the trailer we see Robbie's character
chopping off the pink and blue tinge
tips of her hair in one shot and this
isn't just a play on the fact that
people often enjoy a makeover after a
breakup Harley Quinn's hair was a big
part of her costume in Suicide Squad and
having Robbie cut it off a seemingly
symbolic of the character moving on from
that much derided movie but can she move
on from the Joker completely the opening
shot of the trailer sees Harley Quinn
and her new sidekick Cassandra Cain
walking down a deserted Road with the
bright lights of Gotham City scape in
the background but the purple light in
the foreground seems to suggest that her
experiences in the Joker's colorful Club
lit world are still following her for
the time being
one of the standout moments from the
first birds of prey trailer sees Harley
Quinn lying in what appears to be her
own apartment throwing knives at a crude
picture of her ex that she's pinned to
the wall the drawing resembles Jared
Leto's Joker though Harley neglected to
draw on his tacky forehead tattoo yeah
you remember that thing Suicide Squad
director David Ayer attempted to make
his version of the Joker stand out from
the rest by giving him plenty of ink in
a shiny mouth grill for good measure but
he later admitted that having the word
damaged tattooed across the Joker's
forehead was kind of one step too far he
wrote on Twitter in my mind it was meant
for Batman after he smashed Joker's
teeth for killing Jason Todd but some
people found it alienating for us this
toning down of the Joker's worst
excesses seems like another instance of
birds of prey distancing itself from
Suicide Squad even though we likely
wouldn't be getting this movie at all if
that one hadn't first laid the ground
for Harley's most fantabulous
emancipation Dinah Lance aka Black
Canary is one of the original members of
the birds of prey in DC's new 52
continuity and the birds of prey movie
seems to be taking inspiration from this
version of the character who's being
portrayed on screen by jurnee smollett
Bell Lance appears early in the trailer
chatting with Harley over a drink it
seems like this may be a scene of Dinah
being recruited onto Harley's new team
we see several snippets of Lance
performing on stage during the trailer
which won't come as a surprise to DC
fans in the comics the character fronts
a band named Black Canary and DC has
even overseen the production and release
of real music by the fictional group
this being a comic book universe
she also doubles as a crime fighter her
signature metahuman superpower is a
sonic scream known as the canary cry
which is an incapacitating sound that
leaves her enemies helpless eagle-eyed
fans will have noticed that the movie
version will have this power too in the
trailer we see a martini glass start to
shake as the vigilante sings on stage we
cut away before she hits the high note
you and McGregor is playing the big bad
and birds of prey his character Romans
Ionis goes by black mask in the comics
because he wears you guessed it a black
mask
that's a pendant McGregor's version of
the character won't be totally
comic-book accurate when it comes to
appearance on the page his mask is
burned into his skin so severely that is
actually indistinguishable from his
actual face adding some extra grim
darkness is the fact that the masks
material was carved from his mother's
coffin considering we see plenty of
McGregor's face in the trailer that
clearly isn't the case here but there is
some subtle foreshadowing about the
looks Ionis may adopt in the comics this
Gotham mob boss is known for being
mentally unstable and it appears as
though McGregor's black mask will share
that trait at one point we see him in a
state of clear distress just over his
shoulder a figure with a black face
looms large could this be the moment
that sigh onus goes full villain and
becomes the black mask that Harley Quinn
and her crew will have to take
out one thing we know for sure is that
he has a fascination with Harley and one
way or another he's in the way of her
full emancipation sticking with the
villains there's a shot of sionis
talking to Victor Zsasz a psychotic
serial killer from the comics this won't
be his first movie appearance he was a
supporting villain in Christopher
Nolan's Batman Begins escaping from
Arkham Asylum during scarecrow and Ra's
al Ghul's short-lived reign of terror
he's also been seen in the Gotham TV
series as a right-hand man in carmine
Falcone ease crime syndicate and it
appears as though he'll be doing the
same thing in birds of prey the version
of mr. zas being portrayed by Chris
Messina looks different from those that
came before him but DC fans can likely
figure out who he is from his scars
zaz was born to a wealthy family but
after he lost his parents in an accident
he fell into a deep depression and
squandered his fortune he went down a
dark path and became a serial killer
making a cut on his arm to mark his
first victim and he didn't stop there
the comic book character has hundreds of
scars on his body keeping a tally of all
the people he's killed
does Harley Quinn have a pair of pet
hyenas of course she has a pair of pet
hyenas and we get a good look at one of
them in the first trailer like Harley
Quinn herself bud and Lou named after
legendary comedy duo Abbott and Costello
make their debut in Batman the Animated
Series but with later crossover to DC's
comics at one stage both were stolen by
thieves who attempted to auction them
off but Quinn located her babies and put
an end to the racket it looks as though
a version of this will play out in the
movie Quinn previously has been shown
acquiring bud and Lou during a raid of
the Gotham zoo but in the birds of prey
trailer she appears to get at least one
of her hyenas from some kind of exotic
animal dealer in a later shot the animal
runs at the dealer who we can only
assume meets a violent end in one of the
trailers standout shots Quinn shares
what looks like a piece of candy with
her new
lady in the [ __ ] style there's a
musical feel to the birds of prey
trailer not only do we see jurnee
smollett Bells Black Canary performing
at a club that seems to be important to
the plot it seems pretty clear that it's
owned by you and McGregor's black mask
blasts patrons if they're having a good
time but Harley Quinn herself has a song
and dance number in which she channels
Marilyn Monroe's performance of diamonds
are a girl's best friend from the 1953
film Gentlemen Prefer Blondes though
it's a much darker version Quinn has a
typically deranged look on her face
during the routine and the suited men
surrounding her all wear black masks we
know that tae Onis has a thing for Quinn
could he convince her to start working
for him at the club Harley goes through
a number of costume changes in the
trailer none of which are as
ridiculously revealing as her Suicide
Squad outfit but we can't see her
agreeing to wear this particular getup
the scene is most likely some kind of
dream or nightmare sequence inspired by
her fear of the film's antagonist if
that's true however it obviously won't
last as Harley puts it in the trailer
she isn't known for being a member of
the birds of prey in the comics but
Renee Montoya played by Rosie Perez
looks like she'll fit right into the
movie squad on the page the character
starts out as a no-nonsense cop but she
ends up quitting the Gotham City Police
Department when she grows tired of the
corruption judging from one of the shots
we see of her in the trailer she's going
to leave the force pretty early in the
movie she can be seen walking through a
room full of male cops with a box under
her arm seemingly having cleared out her
desk in the comics Montoya eventually
takes on the moniker the question
originally used by an investigative
journalist who sought to end corruption
by any means necessary
she's also known for being openly gay
though there's nothing in the first full
birds-of-prey trailer to suggest that
aspect of her character just yet her
superhero costume isn't quite as purple
as it is in the comics but a few small
things in the birds-of-prey trailer
suggest mary elizabeth winstead Helena
Bertinelli aka Huntress will be somewhat
faithful to the source material some of
the details are more obvious than others
she's going to ride a motorcycle and
wheel the
crossbow for example in the comics
Helena a so-called mafia princess of the
Bertinelli crime family was taken in by
her Sicilian aunt and uncle after her
family was massacred and they taught her
archery among other skills that she
later put to use as a vigilante in
Gotham
another Huntress character trait is that
she's a deeply religious person this
leads us to believe that the third shot
in the trailer of a woman praying in a
church is Bertinelli we only see her
from behind but at this early stage in
the trailer the ladies that will become
the birds of prey are clearly being
introduced and DC fans have been able to
figure this one out in a later shot a
woman wearing what appears to be the
same modest outfit is strung upside down
alongside two other females by black
mask so she appears to have previous
contact with the villain prior to
hooking up with Harley Quinn in the game
in the comics Cassandra Cain is a member
of the bat family at one point taking on
the mantle of Batgirl but the version of
Cassandra we see in the birds-of-prey
trailer seems pretty far removed from
the badass she is on a page in DC's
comics Cain is a talented martial artist
raised by assassin parents who taught
her how to fight instead of teaching her
how to speak but LJ Bosco's version of
the character can clearly talk in the
film's first trailer so we know that she
won't be mute in the movie the
big-screen Cassandra Cain must have
something about her however because
black mask appears to be after her for
some reason the plot of birds of prey
seems like it revolves around the team
protecting Cain from the ruthless crime
lord by any means necessary
with the youngster becoming a reluctant
sidekick to Harley Quinn along the way
psycho chick could never qualify mention
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]